tenait bon soir qu'elle tandem quel doux
et quelle énergie
surtout si on additionne l'énergie du
kiné la voûte vous savez il faut il vaut
mieux alors l'énergie avec une haie à
côté de vous constituer pendant le
tournage en plus du plaisir en juillet
et que du plaisir et puis ce qui est
formidable avec fabrice luchini c'est
que max et côté exubérant comme ça parce
qu'il l'est dans la vie ces quelques
c'est un acteur c'est très généreux avec
ses partenaires et vont là où on a eu
que du plus agile et c'est vrai même pas
typé les ses imitations il est toujours
il est toujours élégant il n'est pas
lourd comme on dit non ça ne pouvait
être que du tignet personne n'ose pas
pour moi oui moi je n'ai moi quand on va
on a commencé on a commencé à me donner
d'autres noms d'acteurs des très bons
acteurs d'ailleurs les j'ai dit que je
vois vraiment pas quelqu'un d'autre que
fabrice torre qu'est ce qui vous a
décidé à faire le signe finalement parce
que vous étiez très réservé au début
n'aviez pas un vilain simon parle de
jenny mais c'est encore lui quand on m'a
présenté
si antoine duléry mon ami acteur qui
joue d'ailleurs le rôle de tuchan
turquie russie va place dans le film qui
se fait happer qui deux semaines c'est
lui qui m'a amené ce scénario et qui m'a
dit li le c'est un copain mois de
marseille qui l'a et qu'il l'a écrit bon
et s'il s'agit de géniale idée je ne
veux pas faire un film sur genêt idée ça
m'intéresse pas moi je vais je veux être
acteur joue aider d'autres personnages
mais pas je vais pas jouer johnny
hallyday il m'a dit minute quand même tu
verras parce que tu es tu n'es pas donné
l idée tu tu ne connais pas le chanteur
a donné l'idée donc tu vas jouer un
personnage qu'il ne connaît pas alors
précisément c'est un film sur un monde
parallèle où johnny hallyday n'existe
pas un film un peu sur le destin sur des
chemins que tout doit finir le restera
toute honnêteté une comédie c'est un
film sur le destin parce que si dans
l'autre vie à rendez-vous manqués fait
que notre destin aurait pu être un autre
destin faire autre chose avec d'autres
groupes d'amis à l'autre métier
peut-être écart a été validée
l'idée est géniale idée s'il y avait eu
un autre embrayage je vous arrivait
parfois non non je vais je suis non je
fais un métier qui me passionne je suis
un métier que j'aime beaucoup
j'adore les gens j'adore mon public ce
sont des gens généreux moi j'essaie
d'être g de leurs deux nuls à gnjilane
générosité qu'il me transmettent quand
je vois nos sources est ce que vous
trouvez par exemple que justement au
cinéma vous rend justice est ce que vos
qualités d'acteurs ont toujours été vu
comme elle le devait vous savez moi est
ce qu'il est en double casquette
depuis longtemps on dit toujours johnny
et bien c'est dommage qu'il soit dans un
mauvais film
donc voilà le dira pas cette chance
alors bon alors je suis content d'avoir
donné ses tournées à celui ci au moins
20 jours - au moins les gens moi je
pense qu'ils prendront plaisir à voir
voir jean philippe leur part n'ont
justement et c'est peut-être plus facile
pour vous tous les ans philippe que de
jouer à l'idée mais oui parce que je
jouais chez j'ai joué le partage le
d'agents pulse m kylie qui n'est pas
donc devenu donné à l'idée donc qui
connaît pas ses chansons on regarde moi
puisque je n'étais n'existe pas dans
ceux dans ce monde parallèle et donc
j'ai joué à jean philippe smet qui
connaît pas de celle alors un moment un
moment assez difficile dans le film est
très émouvant justement c'est comment
apprend temps à jouer la première fois à
chanter la première fois c'est le cas
d'une semblant se faire toujours de
l'acquis on se sort toujours du dos de
ceux qui ont dû au début c'est vrai que
je chantais différemment je manque la
salle par exemple de tennessee c'est de
la chanson qu'on va baisser le prix
michel berger à l'époque la première
fois qu'une la joue au piano je les
écoute et j'ai trouvé que c'était une
très jolie chanson j'ai essayer de
déchiffrer les accords que michel jouer
au piano à la guitare et et j'essaie de
me rappelait vaguement de l'air qu'il
n'avait chanté deux minutes auparavant
donc avec des visitation voilà et je me
suis servi de tout ça pour tout repos
pour ben pour rejouer à l'écran qu'est
ce qu'un monde sans génie c'est l'usiné
pour nous cacher je je ne me prends pas
au sérieux dans la vie je ça c'est bon
avant de changer bailleur elle manque
quand même cette distance et cet humour
c'est ce qui sauve c'est ce qui fait
tenir
je vais je crois que pour durer dans ce
métier il faut pas se prendre au sérieux
je fais rien d'important je fais
simplement des choses pour faire rêver
les gens et et puis que les gens passent
un bon moment voilà c'est je crois que
ce jeu du film aussi mais c'est le cas
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci de me tenir le sidaction tout ah
oui